and welcome to hannity tonight biden's
radical socialist
far left agenda stalled in congress
democrats they're fighting each other
they're lashing out chaos galore
i'm so sad to hear that anyway some are
finally now even questioning
biden's ability to carry out his duties
amid his
obvious now ongoing cognitive struggles
and weakness
others are predictably crying racism
against joe manchin and others
one idiot at the new york times got
completely
triggered at the disturbing sight of
dozens of
american flags that she had to witness
during a rare trip away from new york
city
and meanwhile barack obama as tucker
mentioned
is back at it again after getting
elected
and then reelected to the highest office
in the land
obama just can't seem to stop obsessing
about
what he keeps referring to as the fear
and
resentment of white americans perhaps
obama should direct his fury
at zero experience hunter biden tonight
who now reportedly according to his own
laptop called his own lawyer the
n-word multiple times and newly
unearthed
text messages we'll have a lot more
later so i asked barack
any comments at all for hunter or joe
now you do have to wonder if hunter
learned that kind of violent language
did he learn
from joe remember joe worked with the
former klansmen
robert byrd to stop the integration of
public schools and busing
he didn't want public schools and his
kids to grow up in schools that are
racial jungles his words uh
barack that was your vice president now
we'll get to all of this coming up but
first
we're now months into her role as
biden's borders are
and vice president kamala harris is now
finally on a mission
to fix the ongoing crisis don't expect
kamal though to actually
visit the border because she can't be
bothered
now watch what is a pretty much train
wreck of an interview with
nbc's lester holt take a look do you
have any plans
to visit the border at some point you
know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this whole
this whole thing about the border we've
been to the border
we've been to the border you haven't
been to the border i
and i haven't been to europe and i mean
i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border
i don't actually get what's so funny
kamala and what is with the constant
never-ending nervous laugh
now of course it's true she hasn't been
to europe but i would guess she probably
hasn't been to the moon either
but uh guess what there's no border
crisis in europe
or from the on the moon that we can tell
but border czar kamala harris
just doesn't seem to understand why she
would ever actually need to visit the
border
in order to address the crisis at the
border
i've been there 14 times kamala you'll
learn a lot
trust me after all kamalas seems to only
be worried about the root causes of
migration
which he is blaming on climate change
which of course is a massive lie and
you're now looking at the actual root
cause of this year's mass
migration and it's not climate change
right there
the problem is caused by joe and kamala
they're the ones that ended the stay in
mexico policy
they stopped the wall construction they
stopped any and all
deportations they vowed to open up all
of our borders and promise free health
care and
amnesty when they were running for
office and one of kamala's favorite
slogans was
say it loud say it clear everyone is
welcome here
well on the campaign trail joe biden
actually told migrants to surge the
border on day one
he told them to come they're telling us
that's why we're coming
we're believing them take a look what i
would do as president
is several more things because things
have changed i would in fact make sure
that there is we immediately surge to
the border
all those people are seeking asylum they
deserve to be heard that's who we are
where a nation says if you want to flee
and you're fleeing oppression
you should come all right joe telling
migrants to come
and they did in record levels many now
decked out in biden campaign gear thanks
for letting us in joe
and even the president of guatemala he's
now blaming joe
and kamala for the ongoing surge
lecturing both of them
take a look the message changed too
we're going to reunite families and
we're going to reunite children
the very next day the coyotes were here
organizing groups of children to take
them to the united states
we asked the united states government to
send more of a clear message to prevent
more people from leaving
no casino
this week kamala harris finally told
migrants oh
not to come because she believes they'll
be turned away
which all of us know is a lie nobody is
being turned away and that's the message
they're getting every single day
nobody in the biden harris
administration is upholding the law
the exact opposite is true everybody
knows it
joe and kamala they are aiding and
abetting all of this law
breaking and you're paying for it now
regardless of that fact congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
even though everyone's getting in was
extremely triggered by kamala's comments
but don't expect aoc to actually go
visit the border herself
and weep uncontrollably for the photo op
like she did at that chain league
fence when donald trump was president so
let not
your socialist heart be troubled
congresswoman because
as we speak the biden administration is
dispersing
migrants all over the country nobody's
being turned away
facilities continue to exceed capacity
and get this so far this year the border
has now experienced
the most illegal crossings in more than
10 years
by the way in most cases more than 20
years and the year is far from
over so tonight we have to ask once
again
is biden's borders are kamala harris
ever
actually gonna bother to visit the
border uh
kamala i've been on helicopter horseback
all-terrain vehicle i've been out on
foot
uh i've done i've been there when gang
members are arrested i've been to the
drug warehouses i've seen the tunnels
dug from mexico to the u.s you might get
an education
try it anyway as per usual circle back
jen sake short on details take a look
when the vice president is asked if she
has plans to visit the border
she says we've been to the border even
though she has not as vice president
well as the vice president she does
speak for
the actions of the people in the
administration she certainly helps
oversee i expect that sometimes she may
go to the border
as we understand it though her main
focus is to try to address the root
causes
of migration did somebody decide here
that it would not be helpful for her
to go to the border and talk to people
who just migrated here
well again i think that at some point
she may go to the border we'll see
all right clearly the biden
administration wants to sweep the crisis
under the rug and pretend like it's no
big deal but as we have now detailed for
months there are serious national
security dangers
all associated with joe's border surge
now one such danger involves the mexican
cartels
they're now reaping the rewards of the
ongoing surge
not only are they making money from
human trafficking
but with border agents preoccupied with
mass illegal
immigration it's taking up all of their
resources
the cartels the drug smugglers these
operations are
increasing on a massive scale los
angeles county
they just conducted what is their
largest drug operation
in history and that says a lot hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else